ci sono domande a cui un uomo almeno una
volta nella vita deve andare incontro
sono domande scomode la cui risposta
potrebbe portare a liti furibonde oa
discussioni infinite
sono domande che mutano partono come
innocue quesiti sul gusto personale e si
trasformano diventando dei mostri di
insicurezze disagi mentali e mezze
verità ed una di queste domande sta
girando tantissimo in questo periodo su
internet
mettendomi non poca pressione
psicologica addosso dove mi giro mi giro
vedo un sacco di gente che chiede hai
visto la la land
[Musica]
no perché no non ho avuto il tempo ma se
non fa in casa dalla mattina alla sera
redeye nicchia non è vero ho messo a
posto loro lyon lo sgabuzzino quanto ci
hai messo dei giorni nov abbiamo anche
fatto altro io ho sistemato tutte le
lenzuola del letto il cazzo dici ho
portato formica lennon anca ne ho fatto
una rapina
se sei in cagasotto sono appena
diventato cieco [ __ ] smettila perché
non è visto la la land e non lo so e non
mi ricordo non mentire stronzo dimmi la
verità ed è proprio in momenti come
questi che un uomo crolla tutte le sue
paure le sue ansie le sue incertezze
vengono a galla
non potevo più nascondermi non potevo
più mentire non mi piacciono i musical
non mi piacciono i musical
[Musica]
benvenuti in un nuovo episodio del lake
show con karim usa oh la la land di
tutti i film candidati agli oscar questo
ha letteralmente spaccato a metà
l'opinione pubblica c'è chi lo adora e
lo sta elevando a capolavoro
cinematografico moderno ha un'energia
incredibile dall'inizio alla fine ma
sentito le canzoni quanto sono belle
continua cantar mele in testa ancora
regia inarrivabile a di piani sequenza
che anche kubrick emma stone quella
ragazza è una dea porca [ __ ] ryan
gosling non credo abbia mai recitato
meglio di così in vita sua io me lo
ricordo quando faceva young hercules
bravino lì perché parli ma ovviamente ci
sono anche i detrattori coloro a cui il
film non è piaciuto e hanno il bisogno
di farlo sapere a tutti quanti
non è così bello come dicono sì le
canzoni sono orecchiabili ma loro due
monoposto è terribile e poi troppe
canzoni troppe
io mi stavo per addormentare la parte
centrale lentissima cazzo è comunque
quello non è vero jazz
perché tu sai cos'è il vero jazz ma come
ti permetti tuoi mercato in vita tua
epic no e allora due perfette facce
della stessa medaglia glowing lo yang
due opinioni diametralmente opposte che
però collidono nello stesso punto
internet
voi non la potete vedere ma io che sono
amico con 5mila sconosciuti su facebook
si sta svolgendo attualmente una
battaglia silenziosa nelle rispettive
bacheche
ed è proprio qui che volevo rimane
perché finché è gente normale gente
qualunque passatemi il termine che
esprime un giudizio tutto va bene perché
nessuno lo sa ma guai guai se uno di noi
a farlo
e lì son cazzi ma scusa perché non hai
mai detto che non ti piacciono i musical
ma scherzi io non me lo posso permettere
di dire una cosa del genere perché
scusami ma perché un sacco di gente che
mi segue si aggrappa
tutto quello che dico ah già è vero che
voi vi fate chiamare o non dirlo non
dirlo non dirlo non dirlo non dirlo
influencer tua zia fa il suo col in
tangenziale ma purtroppo ha ragione c'è
un motivo per cui la gente ci chiama
influencer perché letteralmente
influenziamo la mente delle persone
praticamente qualsiasi persona abbia un
po di pubblico su internet diventa
automaticamente l'ok sevier del 2017 ma
con molti più problemi è più capelli
non so che per voi pubblico quello che
sto dicendo può sembrare un po come un
capriccio un pianto del perché voglio
dire le cose però che tutti ci credono e
io quindi non posso dire quello che
vogliono ma queste cose succedono
purtroppo in continuazione e queste cose
intanto escono ed esplodono e finalmente
anche la gente al di fuori riesce a
capirlo basti pensare cosa è successo a
più di pai c'è stato contro di lui un
attacco mediatico da parte di alcuni
siti di informazione che è stato
imbarazzante è stato accusato di essere
un nazista antisemita per aver detto due
battute del cazzo nei suoi video tanto
che la disney è arrivata al dover
chiudere i rapporti con lui per questa
cosa qua perché perché sanno benissimo
che con tutta la gente che segue felix
qualcuno potrebbe essere benissimo
influenzato anche da una semplice
battuta questa tra l'altro è l'ennesima
prova che al di fuori di youtube
veniamo tutti presi a pesci in faccia
presunti esperti in altri settori
palesemente ci odiano tutti e nessuno di
loro chi per una ragione chi per l'altra
riesce a prendere sul serio
niente che venga prodotto sul web però
mortacci loro come ci si fiondano quando
succede qualcosa che non va mai parlare
delle cose buone
prendiamo un altro esempio un esempio
uno strano leggermente diverso ma sempre
nello stesso contesto prendiamo in
questo caso creta menchi è stata scelta
come uno dei giudici di sanremo ed è
scoppiato ovviamente il casinò tutti ad
additarla come non idonea al contesto
senza diventare l'avvocato del diavolo e
dover difendere una persona che neanche
conosco
vi siete mai soffermati a chiedervi il
perché sia stata scelta a greta me
perché ha fatto i pompini alle persone
giuste non lo so non credo perché è una
delle più grandi esperte di musica in
italia non lo so potrebbe o forse perché
magari la sua caratteristica è il saper
influenzare il suo enorme ma giovani
pubblico e poterlo magari portare a
guardare una trasmissione che neanche
sanno cosa cazzo sia ecco forse questo
sì e vuoi venire la madonna e quanta
cazzo sarà mai sta gente che si lascia
influenzare ragazzi hanno tutti i
[ __ ] ed avete ragionissimo prende
anche solo il 10 per cento
il 10 per cento di 10.000 iscritti è un
conto ma il 10 per cento di tre o
quattro milioni di persone
direi che sono decisamente altri numeri
ci sono alcune persone che semplicemente
dicendo questo film e mi piace o questo
film non mi piace riuscirebbero ad
influenzare talmente tanta gente che
questa cosa qua influirebbe anche se un
minimo ma influirebbe sul mercato di
quel film e parallelamente sempre più
addetti ai lavori ci odiano per loro
siamo dei fenomeni da baraccone con un
potere contrattuale e decisionale
gigantesco siamo praticamente donald
trump che fa la bombola passi alla casa
bianca ed è per questo che non mi
esprimo su la la land è quindi cosa fai
non parli più di nulla
9 nov bisognerebbe trovare il modo
giusto per farlo bisognerebbe riunire
tutte le persone che credono a quello
che dico
sotto lo stesso tetto cosa dove le
persone mi rispettino per quello che
dico
a prescindere se sia vero o falso un
movimento a 5 k
lo schifo e musical ho dormito guardando
che mostra le macchine a idrogeno
[Musica]